[Music]
hi my name is Annie Onishi Annie is a
surgical resident at Columbia University
today I'll be breaking down clips from
movies and TV about the emergency room
and the operating room again roll the
clip
cardiopulmonary bypass the good doctor
doesn't have adequate support and won't
be able to close cardiopulmonary bypass
is a technique to allow the heart to
stand still to allow surgeons to operate
on the heart while a machine takes the
blood out puts oxygen in and puts the
blood back into the patient stitch five
hours 23 minutes well it's great to
allow the heart to stand still so the
surgery can be performed bypass has some
downsides the patient dies the longer
you're on bypass the more likely you are
to have bleeding complications the more
difficult it is to restart the heart
after the operation sometime six that
was 48 minutes six hours and 48 minutes
is an obscenely long bypass time how
long has he been on bypass by past times
in reality range more along the lines of
45 minutes two to two-and-a-half hours
two hours to hollywood rarely gets a
good representation of what bypass
surgery actually looks like damn it self
extubation The Sopranos self extubation
is when a patient removes his or her own
endotracheal tube which is the tube that
connects the patient's airway airway box
to the ventilator which is the machine
that's breathing for them it's actually
not as hard as you would think to do
that that's good right that means
breathing on his own little old ladies
who you'd think never in a million years
would be able to do it can do it this
tends to get everybody very excited and
the ICU like a family I always wait up
because in those moments the patient may
not be able to protect his or her own
airway they had to put the tube back in
face transplant face off
[Music]
my first thought is oh my god you can't
use cautery on the skin like that that's
very poor form it can leave burn marks
it's just not really the technical way
we make skin incisions the other sort of
suction cup device while it looks great
on camera in reality a harvesting of a
facial structures would take hours and
hours and hours as the surgeon very
carefully removes muscles arteries veins
nerves and the like face transplant has
really come a long way initially
described in France and has been
successfully completed here in the
United States and a number of patients
with devastating injuries to their
Airways their mouths their eyes it's
really not a cosmetic procedure at all
it's life-changing and life-saving for
these patients who otherwise can't live
normal lives I'm here today because I
want others to see that there is hope
beyond the injury old-school
defibrillator paddles chips
we have coarse v-fib let's get an
amplification right away please
show me those chest compressions one
more time
those are without a doubt the weakest
chest compressions I have ever seen if
you're not sweating giving chest
compressions you're not doing it right
so they say that this patient has coarse
v-fib hoarse be fit which is a type of
ventricular fibrillation a rhythm that
will require dose of electricity looks a
little bit of between given to me as you
can see here they're also taking their
dear sweet time getting the pads on the
patient
[Music]
Hollywood loves the manual defibrillator
paddles I think it gives the doctor
something to do on camera
in reality it's these it's really these
stickers that are used more commonly hnd
let's take a look at scrubs don't worry
about the patient Turk was already there
learning by doing these days modern
defibrillators are pretty idiot-proof
they have a technology that senses what
the patient's rhythm is and will deliver
a shock only if indicated dr. Turk here
he's using an older school defibrillator
that's not obviously sensing that the
patient is just ously turns out the guy
was just sleeping attached to a faulty
monitor and he is able to deliver a
shock even though it's inappropriate
again seen in the thing I hate when that
happens a professor in charge of his own
heart surgery Chicago med give me a 20
millimeter Dacron graft and a 3o protein
stitch no no no no it's pretty
unrealistic that this person wouldn't be
sedated just a little bit did I fail to
teach you proper surgical technique
definitely not able to participate in
the goings-on of his own open heart
operation
I thought the 300 was appropriate that's
it you're out if we're gonna get real
technical though I do kind of agree with
the crotchety old guy 300 sutures a
little bit too big to be sewing on the
vena cava whoa do not touch me with that
torture device flatlining pop star I
love the road you know this is kind of a
perfect job for me but my favorite
freeze on thing is flatlining
flatline is when you technically lower
your heart rate until what you're dead
what Bill Hader is describing here as
flatlining is what we in the medical
field will call asystole which is
complete cessation of all electrical
activity in the heart you can catch a
glimpse of the afterlife I really would
not recommend to viewers that they try
to pursue this hobby I try to fit in a F
LAN sesh at least once a week one thing
that's inaccurate in this clip is that
asystole can't actually be reversed with
a shock it's one of these sort of
unshockable rhythms it would need to be
treated with infusions of certain
medications like epinephrine Oh fun fact
I do suppose it is possible for you to
poop your pants while you're in asystole
Steel Magnolias withdrawing of life
support so I actually think this is a
pretty fair representation of what
happens when doctors remove life support
one thing that they get right here is
that we do turn off the monitors that
there's very little noise or distraction
yeah it makes for a much more peaceful
environment farting in the Oh are scrubs
good good
whoa whoa what's that smell I don't know
sir I farted yes sir look I'm gonna get
real with you right here right now if
farting in the or got you kicked out
every single time neither me nor any of
my co residents would ever graduate from
residency dude self surgery Master and
Commander
will have to raise a rib right so as
crazy as this sounds self surgery has
actually been documented on a number of
occasions this badass Russian surgeon
dr. Leonid rogas ah've actually removed
his own appendix while he was stationed
by himself in Antarctica nice here's
another example of self surgery and 127
hours
so here we have James Franco playing
aron ralston self amputating his arm
after being trapped in a canyon for a
number of days is the boulder ricocheted
my right hand became trapped by this
rock I think this is a pretty fair
representation it's actually hard for
even me to watch his use of a tourniquet
in this scenario is very smart probably
life-saving unfortunately in today's day
and age a tourniquet is something that
everybody should know how to use I think
they do a pretty great job thank you
crush injury Grey's Anatomy invented on
your flesh to minimize the burns inside
your skin caused by the cement burning
from the inside out so this is actually
a very good very creative representation
of a crush injury and something called a
compartment syndrome compartment
syndrome is when there's some sort of
pressure on the abdomen or actually from
within the abdomen that's preventing
blood from returning normally back to
the heart oh God
the second they removed that last piece
of stone all of those toxins that have
built up rushed back to the rest of the
body he goes into basically immediate
cardiac arrest he loses consciousness
one minor nitpicky point though if they
knew all of this was gonna happen I
think they probably should have
intubated him secured his airway before
they removed that last piece of rock
yeah
organ transplant John Q or
so this is pretty accurate donated
organs actually do end up in the Oh our
and two plastic bags full of ice and ice
water which is represented here that
plastic bag goes in another plastic bag
goes in a special bag goes in a special
box goes in a special cooler all taped
up with real special tape and again
portrayed in One Tree Hill I mean that
sucks we always double bag for safety
the dangers of patient transport Grey's
Anatomy we're going to find out who this
little guy in those stretchers are very
heavy and very hard to control I have
definitely on a number of occasions had
my foot run over by one of these things
you do anymore bowling for doctors to
life and hip-checked by a seizure
resident or a patient transporter Ryan
take out Kepner I would say this is a
pretty accurate representation of the
amount of sass that flies around an
emergency room now to work to here's a
better representation of an incoming
trauma from Chicago men female mid-20s
GCS 3 dashboard and start the windshield
here you can hear the first responders
reporting to the doctors that this
patient has a GCS of 3
GCS 3 that refers to a Glasgow Coma
Scale the Glasgow Coma Scale measures
your mental status on a scale of 3 to 15
you and I sitting here talking right now
have a 15 a carrot has a 315 3 goes in
House Hospital translators getting on
see if maybe we could just tell them
what she's saying and then it can
translate it for us we want to try to
tell you what she's saying
yikes this is really bad this is a huge
violation of this patients rights as a
patient every patient is entitled to an
interpreter who speaks his or her native
language fluently
in any medical encounter he says she
says I can't stand this I wish I was
dead please kill me last time we talked
about removal of live ordnance from a
human body cavity we were talking about
downtown Seattle Grace here we're
looking at a field hospital during the
Vietnam War kid comes in with an
unexploded grenade that's been shot into
his body this is
something we typically learn in medical
school or routine surgical training
something they neglected to tell us
about in med school usually these
operations have to occur in a field
hospital well away from any other
personnel that could get injured when an
if the ordnance explodes it must be an
easier way for a surgeon to make 400 and
$13.50 a month first they would use an
x-ray to sort of figure out what kind of
unexploded bomb would be inside the
patient before very carefully and under
very controlled circumstances removing
it cold school scrubbing in the Nick
waste your time scrubbing it as it suits
you but I told you rolling us to talk
Gallinger through the procedure nothing
more germ theory really became more
widely accepted in the early part of the
20th century so here you can see this
surgeon dipping his hands in a series of
what looks like iodine solution to clean
his hands before an operation these days
we used a simple rub on alcohol-based
gel very similar to pure all small talk
in the operating room st. elsewhere Oh
your smokes dr. Ehrlich smoked triggers
you small to wheeze not so much as a
puff like any other workplace we talked
about weekend plans we talk about the
weather we talk about politics you name
it 140,000 hits of nicotine a year for
at least 15 or 20 years from talks of
this mess we never gossip about the
patient's you never know what they can
actually hear breaking bad news
contagion she failed to respond okay and
her heart stopped
unfortunately she did die okay
communicating bad news with patients is
one of the worst parts of our job right
one thing that this doctor does that I'm
not crazy about is just speaking to the
distraught husband in the middle of the
hustle and bustle of the emergency room
it's not just at home another thing to
avoid is technical jargon such as failed
to respond feel the response in a state
of high stress patient family members
are unable to process beating around the
bush what are you talking about so the
doctor then does a good job of saying
your wife is dead your wife is dead
during medical school and actually on
going through residency every once in a
while we will work with paid actors who
are
able to simulate these sorts of very
high-stress emotional situations what
happened to her okay
this is definitely how you don't do it
how's my son he's going to be alright oh
yes he's lost his left hand so he's
going to be alright
in my experience there's really no place
for puns in the hospital that's more the
way I would take the news dangerous
patients General Hospital so those are
called four-point restraints they're on
the spectrum of the most extreme sorts
of restraints that we would need to use
for a patient there actually are
five-point restraints which also involve
a vest
sometimes psychiatric patients or
patients in an ICU do need to be
restrained for their own safety and for
the safety of the hospital personnel
around them and here's another dangerous
patient in Thor sometimes we do have to
do what's called chemical restraints
give an intramuscular injection of
something like Haldol which is an
anti-psychotic medication pretty
accurate bullet wounds
game night step one sterile gloves check
yeah I wouldn't necessarily recommend
using wine as a disinfectant for an
emergency backdoor surgery but I guess
between the acidity and the alcohol
content maybe it could work nice and
small there that's really big in my
opinion the bigger the incision the
better it is you're more likely to be
able to see stuff and anytime you're
struggling just make the incision a
little bigger so bullet on the
grapefruit so the entire premise here
that you have to remove a bullet just to
take a bullet out is not exactly
accurate why I know what I'm doing
there's plenty of people walking around
out there with bullets stuck in their
bodies in various locations that aren't
really causing any harm at all Thanks
did you get shot twice
she must have skipped step zero which is
make sure you can't also find the exit
that's the exit wound oh I came nothing
to remove you want to see a guy who
knows what he's doing
check out sugar in No Country for Old
Men he's doing it in a nice clean
sterile setting in his bathroom here
he's mixing some betadine into some
normal saline as a cleansing solution he
even has this pro tip down which is make
yourself a little squeezy bottle by
stabbing holes in the top of the bottle
closing a laceration on a desert island
lost do you have a second I could use a
little help here with what with this
look I do myself I'm a doctor but I just
can't read you to sew that up honestly
if I were Jack I would just leave that
wound open for fear of infection but
listen if you're gonna close it he's not
wrong ever
Patrick pair of jeans the sewing
technique is actually kind of similar to
hand sewing for the wound and here we
are again using alcohol to disinfect a
wound again I think vodka be my personal
choice both for its smoothness and its
flavor tension pneumothorax
Mad Max just collapsing lungs sorry oh
my god that is not how you fix a tension
pneumothorax this is more commonly known
as a collapsed lung every time a patient
takes a breath air escapes from the lung
but is trapped inside the thorax she's
pumping it into her chest cavity she's
collapsing her lungs the classical
standard and safest way to treat
attention pneumothorax is with
thoracostomy drainage or needle drainage
in the first and second intercostal
space in the midclavicular line if you
stab lower like where Mad Max stabs you
are just as likely to hit something like
the spleen or the colon because the
diaphragm is moving up and down safest
way is in the chest where there's really
nothing else I am
now where they get tension pneumothorax
right is here in three kings chest I
pretty much love everything about this
clip I actually think this animation is
very good here it demonstrates the
injury to the surface of the lung that's
allowing air to escape into the thorax
[Music]
here they demonstrate pretty solid
placement of their needle thoracostomy
it's exactly as described second
intercostal space midclavicular line
this is even a little fancier they have
a three-way stopcock that will allow
them to let the air out intermittently
and it's also a great representation
that the patient will feel almost
immediately better I feel better how not
to do a physical exam on a trauma
patient
Twilight though looks like it took quite
a spill how do you feel okay
might experience and post-traumatic
stress or disorientation but your vitals
look good no signs of any head trauma
he's talking about her vitals meaning
her heart rate or her blood pressure
meanwhile he's doing a pretend
neurological exam by flashing the
flashlight in her eyes that's not how we
do it might experience some
post-traumatic stress PTSD is not really
a diagnosis we made great then there in
the ER it's something that sort of
develops later on in a patient's course
I think he'll be just fine
while good-looking this guy is pretty
lazy he's doing a very minimal
superficial check of this patient who
apparently just suffered some big
traumatic accident sounds like you were
very lucky brain death Grey's Anatomy no
this must be the papers the papers you
want me to sign to decide what to do
with my husband now that he's dead but
not really dead he's dead he is legally
dead as a clarification her husband dr.
Shepherd has just been declared brain
dead the definition of brain death is a
legal definition of death the brain stem
is no longer functioning there is no
chance of meaningful recovery do I pull
the plug the phrase pulling the plug
really bothers me because it implies we
are stopping taking care of this patient
terminate all life-sustaining measures
when in reality brain-dead is a legal
definition of death stop all curative
intervention
of all the catheters drains and tubes so
I gotta say shonda rhimes
broke my little heart with this clip I
think this is a really terrible
representation of brain death as
described by Meredith Grey who herself
is supposed to be a doctor a surgeon
just like my husband was I know how this
works
and should understand this complex and
very difficult concept you want to talk
about killing my husband ma'am surgical
knot tying the good doctor need a
ligating suture on the splenic artery
while I make the cut and you do that for
me before this young lady bleeds out on
this Murphy yes
[Music]
so they're doing a trauma splenectomy
here this is one of the quickest most
straightforward operations in the book I
don't know why they're so surprised that
he knows how to do it it's a pinch a
scoop and a staple fire it should not
involve everybody stopping to stare
really nothing to write home about okay
let's move on to the Bell / if you look
at this monitor this is actually a great
representation of what a real patient
monitor would look like yes that top
line is your heart rate tracing 130
because the patient is hemorrhaging
middle line is the patient's at that
third line is what's called the end
tidal co2 that is the amount of carbon
dioxide the patient's body is producing
at that moment and those last numbers
are the blood pressure 84 over 40 maybe
not good doctor but good monitor
an understaffed emergency room
wrongfully accused because of cutbacks
you are the only person on duty balance
and rotate the order you better take a
look at this no thank you
honestly sometimes it feels like our
Hospital is this busy and this crazy and
we're all swamped as much as this but I
think this is probably a little bit of a
stretch multidisciplinary discussions
Grey's Anatomy no one can agree on my
story there are definitely conversations
that take place between general surgery
orthopedics neurosurgery anesthesia dr.
Torres worried that the limbs dr.
Bailey's worried about abdominal crush
injury but ultimately all these people
do have to come together and decide
what's gonna kill the patient first
that's the treatment plan that we should
pursue we work as a team well that man
dies scary 1970s cerebral angiogram The
Exorcist
so this is in old-school representation
of how they used to do cerebral
angiogram which is a picture of the
blood vessels in the brain in this scene
you can see them putting a needle into
the patient's carotid artery you can
tell it's the artery because there's
blood spurting out they're writing a
wire in threading a catheter and then
injecting dye and taking x-rays this dye
is a type of contrast usually with some
iodine in it so that'll show up on
x-rays cerebral angiogram ZAR used to
diagnose problems with the blood vessels
in the brain such as aneurysms or
arterial venous malformations
displacement at all I'm not sure what it
has to do with demonic possession but
I'm sure they were just exploring all
entities at this point we still think
the temporal lobe Oh what are you
talking about conclusion listen I get it
Hollywood has to take some shortcuts for
a dramatic effect or comedic effect but
it's also important to recognize the
difference between fantasy and reality